uh whoopi goldberg
um was
whoopi goldberg was suspended from her
job at the view uh-huh
uh because sh of her comments on the
holocaust
yeah specifically those comments being
that she did not see
uh jewish people as a race she thought
that the holocaust was about white
people killing white people
and the evils of humanity yeah i thought
that's what she was saying it was a more
macro view which is oh hey listen at the
end of the day it's just people treating
people and humanely regardless of race
yeah which you could say about anything
which is always a dumb thing i don't
know why people always gotta do that
with the holocaust that's so weird they
always kind of try to find a way they're
like everybody wants to be a comic when
it comes to the holocaust you know i
think about the holocaust isn't about
jews it's about people yeah it's like a
big premise that they gotta [ __ ]
deliver on not worth it it's the all
lives matter argument yeah yeah it
really is yeah but the easy argument to
say about people saying oh jesus was
saying that they're a race and a
religion and blah blah blah like that's
what al and i were talking about the
other day here's the easy argument we
didn't create that
hitler did he's the one that said that
jews were the inferior race so it's like
talk to him
he just said you're inferior
but he didn't decide you guys were a
race yes he's a tuberculosis i think in
mind confidence like where the
tuberculosis of
uh a race where in jesus bro you ready
you read mineconf yeah you're a piece of
[ __ ] right but i guess a powerful book i
was like how did he convince all these
[ __ ]
what he was doing to get on board no no
i i think that the idea that the jews
are a race started way before yes i'm
just saying but like that's an easy
argument for me to say like because
people come at me all the time like oh
you guys consider yourself a racist
let's let's explain real quick okay
race is invented i don't want to sound
like some [ __ ] liberal arts professor
here but like a somali dude is just as
much genetically uncommon as like a
swedish guy right so like racist markers
are very slight yeah so like if race is
a whatever social construct or whatever
it is if we acknowledge that race is
invented but we acknowledge that race
exists we have invented it you can't
stop the sliding scale
right everybody wants to have wants to
or believes in their own race so you
can't really take it away from people
like how many races are there back in
the day there was three right it was
black white asian yeah well you guys
want your own race indian we probably
indian pakistan we look at desi whatever
we look at its own race arabs probably
want their own race or middle eastern
people want their own race right latinos
latinos want their own race right and
then you have caribbean latinos then you
have like central american afro latino
afro then you have native american like
so each person is kind of developing
their own
sect kind of based on like physical
characteristics i think the interesting
thing about jews is is that it is
probably the most diverse
in what we view as racial
right group whereas like yes you have
light skin black people dark skinned
black people and their facial
characteristics change like an
extraordinary amount when you go from
east to west africa right even body
types everything but latinos it's like
you can have blonde hair blue eyes and
you can have the suit the dark is a dark
latino so i would say latinos is the
closest and probably actually equivalent
because you have jewish latinos as well
but like you have black jews yeah you
have jews from ethiopia right you have
jews that look like dove
and then you have the whitest of white
jews right so it's an interesting
concept to look at where we're like okay
our idea of race is physical
characteristic
but this
group of people which we also see as a
race
encompasses many different
races
yeah as far as we understand so it is
confusing yeah that being said if we're
just going to play the game of everybody
has their race why are you stopping it
at jews that's a little weird
but just to that point yeah if the
conversation has to deal with the
holocaust just one thing just one thing
and the reason why whoopi does it
is because whoopi has existed in
hollywood for so long that jews and
white people are synonymous to her
in the same way that i'm sure like a lot
of basketball players see jews as like
the my agent or the owner of the team
and they just start to see these white
guys right so they're not interacting
enough with maybe black jews they're not
interacting enough with sephardic jews
they're not interacting with all these
different types of jews right so it's a
kind of like newer thing for them for
sure but if you're going to say that you
can have these arguments now and present
day with different groups but if you're
talking about the holocaust i even
remove myself because this is something
that happened to
europeans right yeah yeah that's just
puts you in that vacuum you guys were
protected by the moses at that time
well morocco we were yep not all
yeah
morocco's king was lit but you know what
i mean so i'm just saying her argument
has to do with
taking
white people and then separating them
into another race yes in europe so yes
you can't say oh but now in hollywood
you got everything and blah blah blah
and this is humanity so that's an easy
argument for people to say i also want
to say like i don't even think she's an
auntie semi i don't think either i don't
think
but i'm like really you're gonna lean
into that argument right now i'm gonna
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip you can watch full episode at
patreon.com flagrant2 join [ __ ] army
but i gotta tell you guys about lucy
okay look we're all adults here and i
know some of us choose to use nicotine
to relax focus or just unwind after a
long day lucy is a modern oral nicotine
company that makes nicotine gum lozenges
and pouches for adults who are looking
for the best most responsible way to
consume their nicotine it's a new year
why not start it out by switching to a
new nicotine product that you can
actually feel good about okay this is a
no-brainer lucy best in the business i
enjoy some nicotine i'm not going to lie
i enjoy it and i don't really want to
get my nicotine from cigarettes and the
losses the pouches they are phenomenal
so i would recommend using lucy if you
enjoy using nicotine as well you should
definitely check out lucy's products at
lucy.co
go to lucy.co and use the promo code
flagrant to get 20 off all products on
your first order including gum or
lozenges that's lucy.co and use the
promo code flagrant at checkout okay i'm
telling you and i have to uh read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co
and be sure to use that promo code
flagrant
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip i think the biggest thing
was it wasn't like the jews aren't a
race it's like removing jews
from this horrific event that happened
to them it'd almost be like uh if it'd
be like somebody going um
911 happened to all americans yeah and
then us new yorkers being like did it
though
yeah did it really though like yeah it
happened to america it was an attack on
america but like specifically if they go
my brother saw the people jump out the
building if you lived in omaha you
didn't see people jump out the building
in real life and specifically they said
it wasn't an attack on new york it was
an attack on america you'd be like yo
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you don't make this a larger scale
thing [ __ ] yeah exactly if you zoom out
enough yeah we're all humans yes but a
specific group of humans yes were
affected by or was affected by this
thing
and um
like i mean it has deeply impacted their
identity so to kind of remove them from
that and i mean that from 9 11 i mean
anybody who's went through tragic it's
like it'd literally be like listen
slavery happened to americans
did it
yeah a couple irish people were
indentured servants but i'm pretty sure
we know the group that it was targeted
and you're so you're touching on such a
trigger point because you guys have said
this to me you explained the jews really
are fearful this could happen again so
anything that me that seems like it
could be leading down that path there's
gonna be a [ __ ] a reaction on a
thousand yeah so if somebody's saying oh
no the holocaust wasn't even about jews
they're not gonna hear the rest of the
argument they're just gonna hear oh
they're trying to act like this didn't
really happen to us and it wasn't insane
what happened to us and six million of
us didn't die this is a [ __ ] problem
shut this down right now the reaction is
going to be an overreaction 100 percent
and it's understandable now do we think
that she should have been suspended
it's like um
it's stupid but it's like okay can i
suggest something yeah
bring on a jewish person
that can explain to her why it's
offensive yeah that's why i spoke right
away
sorry have the conversation
live with someone who's intelligent and
articulate enough to explain why this is
offensive and why it's important to the
community that it's recognized in this
way right have it live for everybody
else who might also be confused instead
of for two weeks a bunch of fans of the
view who like will be going oh this is
so sensitive why are they doing this is
[ __ ] up it's almost like you stir up
more anti-semitism and create even more
confusion during the process have
someone explain it if the problem is
education which clearly it is
the solution is education not
cancellation yeah i think they're trying
to placate the jewish community to be
like oh when people say [ __ ] up things
they get punished yeah well they're
saying
they are doing that but i don't know if
i don't know if that gets us to a better
place i think it just gets us to a more
silent place yes and then we stop asking
questions that could actually put us in
a position where we really understand
people's feelings right it's i think one
of the big problems especially with like
race and even religion in this country
is like
people are so worried about
having people are so worried about
making a mistake not like what whoopi
made but just making a mistake that
could offend somebody yeah you know what
i mean like you're in like the back of
an uber and like you want to ask the guy
where they're from but you're like i
don't want him to feel like he's not
american or something like that or i
don't want him to feel like he's not
part of this uh let me just not ask
anything at all i don't want to
potentially create some discomfort you
go hey buddy where you from and you're
asking that because you see his [ __ ]
name on the thing and it's got all these
different letters and no vowels and
you're like oh maybe this is going to be
an interesting conversation that we
could have but you're like
and then if he goes to you i'm from
america you're like okay well i guess
this conversation is done i always go oh
are you from new york that's smart and
then they always go no i'm not i go oh
where'd you grow up and and then i'm
like boom dude
it's tough dawg
but but but this is really interesting
what a [ __ ] rigmarole yeah i gotta go
through but no no what you did is you
found a workaround right you asked a
question that you already knew the
answer to so that he alley-oops you for
the question you really want yeah
sometimes they do say yeah i'm from
bushwick right like my parents are in
that dream but i've lived here my whole
life and i go oh right right but but you
asked a fake question to get to the real
question which is
on but which is you being like smart and
working yourselves around this like
uncomfortable situation and the problem
is we're so worried about getting cancer
or making somebody feel uncomfortable
etc we can't even ask the questions
they're gonna stop us from being
ignorant and the ignorance is what's
gonna cause us to be canceled in the
future so educate these [ __ ]
somebody says something offensive bring
them back on and you also got to
understand it's not really a punishment
whoopi goldberg's not hard up for money
you just gave her a two week vacation
little slap on the wrist in a year
everybody forgets about this her two
weeks might be a little stressful at the
end of the day it's not a real
punishment you're just doing this to
appease the masses and quiet the outrage
people yeah but they're always gonna
they're gonna find another outrage yeah
another girl could come on and navarro
could say something that pisses him off
and then that's the thing yeah just have
the conversation i think it gets it gets
dealt with in an actual way now when you
say she gets dependent to spend it's
like [ __ ] she get two weeks vacation if
someone from nebraska said sitting next
to me on a show
911 didn't happen to new yorkers it
happened to all americans yeah i might
swing on them bro yeah there might be
another 911 there might be another one
you know joy behar is [ __ ] bro
isn't she jewish
i don't know i know there's gotta be one
there's gotta be one jewish person gotta
be elise right
i mean those executives at least in the
studio right yeah walk on set
i think i ain't swinging on whoopi she
looks like she fights
bill she built like roy wood jr
now she is
oh [ __ ] do they have any jews on the
show
the bosses uh whoopi whoopee i guess
besides yeah besides miss goldberg yeah
yeah
what up people you just watched a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you